mit ihrem einsatz belegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
in welchem tierkreiszeichen sind sie
geboren bei mir stand die sonne in den
fischen ja die auswirkungen der sterne
und planeten auf uns menschen darüber
wollen wir heute nachdenken und zwar
hier oben in der zürcher sternwarte
urania außerdem bei uns in der sendung
geheimnisvolle tagebücher von donald
trump und ein schweizer naturforscher
und terrorismusverdacht
[Musik]
von stern
willkommen auf dem kurplatz hat das zu
bedeuten dass ich den sternzeichen
fische mit sendern skorpion geboren
solche fragen gehen wir heute nach
[Musik]
hier oben in der altehrwürdigen
sternwarte urania in zürich bin ich
gleich mit einer frau verabredet sie hat
sie in dieser materie den vollen
durchblick
[Musik]
alexander wir kennen uns wir sagen uns
du etwa unter uns gefragt mein
jahreshoroskop sagt mir die kurz
bevorstehende erleuchtung voraus wie
soll ich mich verhalten
ich würde sagen ganz einfach
weitermachen deinem stärke folgen und
sich durch nichts und niemandem ablenken
lassen schon gar nicht durch ein kurzes
das heißt aber dass das horoskop das du
unter anderem schreibt das ist beste
unterhaltung oder wie verstehst du dass
ich will stehen meine arbeit tatsächlich
in erster linie als unterhaltung und als
teil von popkultur aber ich sehe darin
absolut trojanisches pferd in dem ich
ganz ganz viel tiefere wahrheit an die
richtige stelle und vor allem an ein
großes publikum bringen kann ich glaube
das ist unsinn dass deswegen viel spaß
mit einer erneuten wir glauben es wird
vielleicht auch helfen dass wir jetzt in
dieses ominöse wassermann 2000
eingetreten sind was hat das für eine
bedeutung für uns alle
ich würde sagen dass ich darunter diesen
epochenwandel verstehe der sich jetzt
gerade ziemlich offensichtlich vollzieht
und wenn man als astrologisch betrachtet
geht es darum dass wir uns aus dem
erdreich in das luft bereich bewegen und
dass die quasi gesamten energien dadurch
deutlich leichter werden und fröhlicher
und es darum mehr um wassermann themen
geht eben um kommunikation neue
technologie vernetzung mehr freude
connections und ja hoffentlich dann auch
wahre menschliche verbindung das klingt
jedenfalls vielversprechend und dieses
große neue wassermann zeitalter es wurde
schon vor jahrzehnten herbei gesungen
[Musik]
das musical und film her machten die
astrologie in den 70er jahren populär
besonders bei der jüngeren generation
die im anbrechenden zeitalter des
wassermanns eine epoche des fliegens zu
erkennen glaubte wassermann skorpione
oder jung für das persönliche
sternzeichen dürfte allen bekannt sein
bestimmt wird es durch den sonnenstand
zur zeit der geburt doch die astrologie
berücksichtigt auch den mond die
planeten und fixsterne für ihre
auslegungen horoskope gibt es heute in
allen formen für jede lebenslage für die
geburt jahres perioden oder für
lebensbereiche wie liebe oder arbeit die
geschichte der astrologie reicht weit
zurück bereits 3000 jahre vor christus
begannen die mesopotamien im fernen
osten den himmel systematisch zu
durchforsten
die astrologen wissenschaftler ihrer
zeit entdeckten wiederkehrende muster
schrieben sie nieder und sucht nach
deren bedeutung
daraus destilliert die prognosen für die
ernte oder kriege und kreierten die
zwölf noch heute bekannten tierkreis zu
rechnen auch die griechen verbanden das
himmlische mit dem irdischen leben ihre
götter hatten mit den planeten einen
stellvertreter am firmament jupiter
stand für den göttervater zeus und damit
für das wissen während die liebesgöttin
venus die gefühlswelt repräsentierte
obwohl die kirche und auch die
aufklärung die astrologie als aberglaube
abtaten hielt sich die stern deutung
hartnäckig und ist verantwortlich für
die eine oder andere haar streikende
entscheidung neben machthaber in burma
der 60er jahre änderte so zum beispiel
den linksverkehr über nacht oft rechts
war als ein astrologe ihm das so ein
fohlen hatte dieser prophezeit dem
abergläubischen diktator nämlich nur
schlechtes in verbindung mit der linken
seite heute ist der blick in die sterne
mehr denn je im trend
das horoskop gehört in magazinen und
zeitungen nicht umsonst zu den
beliebtesten zeit und gerade in krisen
wieder corona pandemie boomt die
astrologie
[Musik]
da wäre es jetzt nacht könnten wir hier
durch das teleskop die planeten sehen
welchen einfluss haben sie auf uns
menschen wie planeten sind in meiner
wahrnehmung so was wie sehr gute freunde
die uns helfen unseren weg auf dieser
sternenkarte zum bestmöglichen ergebnis
von allen und allem
so finden im prinzip ist es war also wie
seine art ja karte auf der wir dann
unseren weg gehen können
gute freunde sind diese planeten und die
zwei freuen der jupiter und saturn die
haben sich ja historisch angenähert im
dezember was war das für eine wirkung
auf die menschen die hat so ein date wie
man es sich nur vorstellen kann und
natürlich betreffen die sich öfter mal
ich glaube so alle 20 jahre aber auf
diese zahlen kann man mich nur
mathematik war noch nie meine stücke
nicht festlegen auf jeden fall ist es so
dass dieses die wirkung von diesem
treffen sehr sehr sehr viel licht auf
unseren planeten gebracht hat und nicht
umsonst war ja vom stern von bethlehem
die rede und die vorstellung finde ich
natürlich fantastisch hier in der
sternwarte wird in der astronomie
gefrönt eine wissenschaft wie verhält es
sich mit der astrologie
ich glaube astronomie und astrologie
waren tatsächlich auch mal sehr sehr
viel bessere freunde und ich hoffe dass
es auch wieder so sein wird das ich
diese unterschiedlichen fachgebieten
einfach auch mehr annähern dürfen weil
in dem moment wo man sich besser
versteht und wo weniger quasi inhalt und
form diskussion stattfinden und es
eigentlich nur darum geht gemeinsam
neben den besseren weg zu finden für
alle meine geheime vision ist ja auch am
time square auf dem der mond stand
irgendwie angezeigt wird und ich finde
sollte wie der wetterbericht auch einen
kosmischen planeten bericht geben weil
dann wirst du jeder a merkurs rückläufig
okay wir unterschreiben die sind
vertrags vielleicht besser in zwei
wochen sie sind denn die leute gestellt
zu astrologie kann man behaupten dass
die meisten leute ihr horoskop genau
dann glauben wenn es positiv ist oder
eben ausrede benutzen für irgendein
handicap zu übertünchen wir
wahrscheinlich würde ja auch total nahe
liegen und ich meine dass das thema
überhaupt so viel aufmerksamkeit bekommt
und dass ich überhaupt so darüber
sprechen darf das zeigt ja schon dass es
im zeitgeist einfach ein wahnsinniges
interesse daran gibt und ich glaube auch
dass jetzt im prinzip das ganze alte
wissen jetzt uns einfach wieder einholt
und ich glaube auch dass man ja
irgendwann als menschheit in die demut
kommen muss zu verstehen dass wir hier
auf diesem planeten natürlich unter dem
einfluss von anderen planeten stehen ich
meine nicht umsonst bewegt der mond ebbe
und flut und ich weiß ja nicht was also
ich merke deutlich und das ist da bin
ich zum glück ja auch nicht die einzige
die sich dafür interessiert sind die
einfach darüber spricht und die einfach
ganz klar diese diskussion nicht mehr
führen möchte ob das jetzt alles humbug
ist oder nicht
wie sehr lebst du noch den zyklen des
horoskops der stern gucke ich in mein
horoskop in das horoskop wollen und was
mir eigentlich das größte anliegen ist
es nicht nach vorne zu schauen oder nach
hinten zu schauen sondern in der
gegenwart zu sein und die aktuelle zeit
qualität so zu lesen dass es für mich im
besseren tag gibt und für alle die in
meinem tag sind auch dann bis erste
alexander
[Musik]
in einer woche endet die ära trauma und
wer hätte je gedacht dass all das
möglich wäre
was wir erlebt haben die stürmung des
kapitols all die lügen die skandale die
gewalt trotz alledem vielleicht sollten
wir probieren diese ära mit einem lachen
zu beenden und genau das versuchen jetzt
die tram tagebücher warnung
dieser beitrag könnte zu verärgerungen
depression oder anderen verstimmungen
führen oder sie fühlen sich darin
bestätigt was sie immer schon zu wissen
geglaubt haben sie kommen spät zu spät
vielleicht und enthüllen erschreckendes
ein anonymer herausgeber der sich selbst
als diener des volkes bezeichnet
veröffentlicht nun die tagebücher und
private korrespondenz von donald trump
briefe und notizen zutiefst persönliches
und politisch brisantes
[Musik]
während dieser bilder wäre der sturm auf
das kapitol ja wäre donald trump als
präsident vermeidbar gewesen wenn diese
intimen details früher bekannt geworden
wären
oh ja wenn man nur toms vater fred
geglaubt hätte der schrieb bereits 1967
an eine freundin der familie
ihm fehlt alles was ein mann braucht um
im leben bestehen zu können
er ist unbewiesen ungebildet sprunghaft
egozentrisch jähzornig und
vergnügungssüchtig und seine
selbstverliebtheit überschreitet jedes
mir bekannte maß das war noch leicht
untertrieben denn die ära john
offenbarte eine neue form politischer
kultur den egozentrismus die ursache
eine tief verwurzelte
persönlichkeitsstörung
erste symptome dafür finden sich zuhauf
in den dokumenten die das tagebuch
enthält als dort schon 20 war reist der
neil armstrong als erster mensch zum
mond da wollte dort dabei sein
irgendwie und schrieb an armstrong
dessen antwort für den jungen dort
zutiefst verletzend gewesen sein muss
lieber doch leider kann ich dir deine
bitte die worte donald war hier auf den
mond zu schreiben nicht erfüllen
doch ich werde dir kurz zu winken wenn
ich gelandet bin
[Musik]
liegt in kränkungen wie dieser die
wurzel allen irrsinns weil das mit dem
mond nicht klappte mussten frauen
herhalten als statussymbol für den
gesellschaftlichen höhenflug kommt wird
zum geilen tiger auf dem parkett der
boulevardpresse die begierig seiner nähe
sucht das tagebuch enthüllt wie medien
mogul rupert murdoch drops expertise
nutzen will
sehr geehrter herr trump man kennt sie
als wohlhabenden mann der auch viel vom
zarten geschlecht versteht es wäre uns
eine ehre wenn sie für die new york post
eine rangliste der besten peep shows in
new york erstellen könnten
mit freundlichen grüßen rupert murdoch
das war der beginn einer langen
freundschaft ohne murdoch ohne fox news
während nie präsident geworden
jump lieferte den stoff stories und
abstruse ideen und beide kassierten
kräftig an
tief lässt das tagebuch blicken in shops
gedankenwelt dass er bestimmte regionen
des weiblichen körpers nur mit dem blick
eines immobilienmaklers betrachten kann
es nicht ganz neu doch das tagebuch
enthüllt wie manisch erinnern nur an das
eine denkt
der bagger centro fortan schreibt ins
tagebuch
sie wird die englein singen
er begeistert sich so sehr für vladimir
nabokovs lolita dass er ihn als
ghostwriter für seine memoiren
engagieren will
doch nabokov sagte ab politisch brisant
wird das tagebuch wentrup über die
soldaten lästert die den vietnam krieg
verloren haben war schreiber seien sie
eher hingegen habe sich zur selben zeit
seinem ausschweifenden liebesleben
hingegeben den krieg in vietnam haben
sie verloren aber meinen krieg auf den
matratzen ja den habe ich gewonnen und
das war mehr als mein persönliches
witten an
es war mein erster zweiter und dritter
weltkrieg kann das alles wahr sein
hat er wirklich charlie chaplin zur
eröffnung seines traktors eingeladen und
dem tagebuch geraldine chaplin
beschimpft weil sie ihn daran erinnerte
dass ihr vater längst längst tot sei
kann das alles wahr sein
vielleicht vielleicht doch nicht
[Musik]
dieser traum tagebücher verdienen sich
der gleichen methode wie er politik
macht lügen täuschen und fällt sie sind
ein produkt aus der von jump
geschaffenen welt der alternativen
fanden
doch das mit der wahrheit genau so
umgeht wie trump es selbst getan hat
das ist zuweilen sehr unterhaltsam
auch wenn einem das lachen oft im halse
stecken bleibt
[Musik]
donald trump hast du jemals sein
horoskop studiert um herauszufinden wie
daran wirklich tickt ich kann nur sagen
dass es extrem spannend und viele
interpretationsmöglichkeiten gibt und es
geht darum dass zwillinge tatsächlich
unberechenbar sind wäre ist das aller
aller einfach so zu sagen aber was ich
viel interessanter finde ist der
aszendent sein als in der das nämlich
löwe und mehr ego machtspielchen und so
weiter gehen glaube ich nicht danke dass
wir zusammen über die sterne fachsimpeln
konnten danke vielmals alexander koose
sehr gerne
[Musik]
jetzt schauen wir in eine ganz andere
welt johann jakob schuh die der
schweizer im neunzehnten jahrhundert als
naturforscher im peruanischen urwald
unterwegs aber was tun die damals über
die indigene bevölkerung schrieb wirkt
heute verstörend er ist knapp 20 jahre
alt als er 1838 nach peru geschickt wird
sein auftrag für das naturhistorische
museum in neuchatel eine zoologische
sammlung aufzubauen
fünf jahre wird johann jakob und schuhe
die in südamerika bleiben
du solltest mich hier sehe er einen wild
als einen gebildeten herrlich schreibt
er seinem engen freund alfred escher
nach zürich nämlich abends um sechs uhr
zerrissen blutend müde aus dem urwald
nach einer einsamen waldhütte kam war
mein erstes geschäft meine jagdbeute
abzuziehen und zu konservieren und dann
die anatomie aller vögel und säugetiere
zu untersuchen
[Musik]
600 tierpräparate schickt er nach
neuchatel
er verfasst ein standardwerk über die
peruanische vorne
[Musik]
und er beschreibt auch die menschen die
gewohnte melina bestehen aus allen
möglichen menschenrassen europäer dann
mestizen monaten zanders und [ __ ]
letztere vier bilden die fürchterlichste
und verabscheuungswürdige kanal die
vielleicht auf erden existiert aussagen
die den damaligen zeitgeist spiegeln
sagt der argentinische historiker thomas
barth oletti der an der eth zürich
forscht studie war ein typischer
vertreter seiner schicht die ehre
präsentierte die wissenschaftliche elite
europas und diese elite versuchte die
welt orten und mit rassistischen
beschreibungen zu erklären
das bild das dabei entstand legitimierte
die dominanz europas über lateinamerika
[Musik]
diese wissenschaftler trugen eine
verantwortung und ich glaube aus
heutiger warte ist es wichtig zu
untersuchen wie die wissenschaft das
bild der welt verarmte
das naturhistorische museum in neuenburg
beherbergt die tierpräparate die studios
büro mitgebracht hat heute in vielerlei
hinsicht ein wertvoller bestand wie die
biologin und kurdirektorin silvia
bourceau betont die sammlung ist von
großem historischen wert denn sie zeigt
wie damals museen bei der wissens
beschaffung vorteil
[Musik]
sie hat auch einen ästhetischen wert
denn die bildtafeln der fauna peru viana
sind speziell und von hoher ästhetischer
qualität und dann ist die sammlung von
großer wissenschaftlicher bedeutung
viele arten hat judy als erster
beschrieben
und noch heute kommen wissenschaftler
hierher um die exemplare zu studieren
moody war ein wissenschaftler der seine
arbeit macht damaligen standards sehr
gut machte die sammlung und die
publikationen sind sehr wertvoll
doch seine forschung trug dazu bei die
lebensgrundlagen der lokalen bevölkerung
zu bieten an rohstoffen wurde raubbau
betreten nachdem die sie beschrieben hat
trotz seiner verdienste müssen wir uns
also fragen wie sich die wissenschaft
auf die entwicklung der erforschen
länder ausgewirkt hat nach europa
mitgebracht hat johann jakob von tschudi
auch altertümer wie etwa die figur des
eco der gottheit der fruchtbarkeit
bartoli hat eine kopie davon in seinem
büro der originale eco befand sich bis
2014 im bernischen historischen museum
totti hatte in seiner zeit den ideen
entwendet die fragte scherzhaft den
besitzer über diesen heiligen nicht
verkaufen wolle
was aber bittet rüstung zurückwies eine
flasche cognac machte ihn geschmeidiger
2014 verlangte bolivien die rückgabe der
figur die rückkehr der noch heute hoch
verehrten gottheit wurde triumphierend
gefeiert
dieses vermächtnis beschäftigt auch das
ethnographische museum indes hatte der
chordirektor gregoire major steigt ins
archiv
[Musik]
hier lagern zwei kinder mumien die
studie aus peru mitgebracht hat wie das
museum mit ihnen verfahren soll ist
offen
die frage stellt sich ob wir menschliche
überreste
überhaupt ausstellen können und wenn ja
auf welche weise um diese frage zu
beantworten müssen wir hauptsächlich
mehr über ihre herkunft erfragen
darum ist die forschung von thomas war
auch so wichtig für uns
die computertomographische untersuchung
lieferte immerhin ein paar medizinische
fakten zu den kindern ihr mumien wie
diese waren im neunzehnten jahrhundert
beliebte studienobjekte in der damals
aufkommenden rassen forschung
andere länder hatten kolonien
die schweiz hatte forscher und händler
aber auch sie war teil des kolonialen
systems in die sammlung spiegelt sich
die globale vergangenheit und
verflechtung der schweiz wieder wer sich
mit juli befasst bekommt einen anderen
blick auf die schweiz des 19
jahrhunderts
[Musik]
der blick in die vergangenheit hilft die
gegenwart besser zu verstehen
[Musik]
die jules verne bahir im turm der
zürcher sternwarte bleibt bis auf
weiteres geschlossen wie so vieles und
wie wir wissen sind auch die
kulturhäuser schon lange zu aus diesem
grund haben wir von kulturplatz ein
wettbewerb gestartet und
kunstschaffenden trotzdem auftritten zu
ermöglichen
[Musik]
seit mitte dezember ist das stadtcasino
basel für das publikum gesperrt
auch hier bleibt die bühne wegen corona
fast immer leer doch heute tönte es hier
ausnahmsweise
concerto scirocco ein musikensemble aus
dem tessin hatte sich vom kulturplatz
gewünscht ein kleines konzert aus ihrem
neuesten noch nicht veröffentlichten
programm auf einer bühne spielen zu
dürfen
trotz veranstaltungs verbot
das international zusammengesetzte
ensemble ist angereist um englische
musik der frührenaissance zu
präsentieren
ich bin juli leiterin des ensemble
concerto di luca bei den spielen und in
diesem programm spiele ich die laute ich
bin zu sein
ich bin als vier pakete war ich spiele
die spielkommission rockmusik ist
interessant und frisch
[Musik]
das stück ist ein maskentanz des
engländers john der zielkurve aus dem
17ten jahrhundert er hat eben diese
diese wunderschöne musik ganz wovor ganz
viel bläser dabei sind oder es ist ganz
speziell in bläser richtung für eine
klangfarbe um das würde natürlich
benutzt immer immer um der eintritte der
könig zum beispiel zu unterschreiben
oder die musik deswegen hat es diese
pumphose große festliche charakter
barockmusik zeichnet sich unter anderem
dadurch aus dass sie auf alten
instrumenten gespielt wird das ensemble
schirokko verfügt über nachgebaute
instrumente es gibt instrumentenbauer
die sich darauf spezialisiert haben das
fagott zum beispiel stammt aus paris
das könnte verstaubt klingen aber
barockmusik ist seit ein paar jahren
sehr populär
alte musik ist ja nicht alles ist
einfach es ist ja klassische musiker ist
kann erstaunlicherweise modern klingen
und durch unsere konzertprogramme wir
wählen stücke eben ganz im sinne von
diese diese besondere leichtigkeit und
besondere eben lebendigkeit von dieser
besonders die frühbarocke musik hat das
drin sehr viel es gibt sehr viel um
emotionen
seit zehn jahren gibt es konzerte
scirocco bereits einige der musiker und
musikerinnen lernten sich schon während
des studiums kennen war die alte musik
selten in orchestern gespielt wird lag
es auf der hand ein eigenes ensemble zu
gründen
vorangetrieben hat diese idee julia
jenny ich bin die leiterinnen dass ich
quasi die ganze maschine weiter trägt
und ich suche projekte ich plane
projekte usw
aber wenn es um musik geht dann sind wir
alle zusammen dran und es gibt schon
erste erfolge seit 2017 hat das ensemble
drei cds veröffentlicht auch das
programm das sie hier im stadtcasino
aufführen soll im februar als cd
aufgenommen werden
wie fühlt es sich an in dem leeren saal
zu spielen
die akustik ist wirklich hervorragend
jetzt und natürlich ohne publikum zu
spielen bedeutet für uns eigentlich noch
mehr engagement weil es fehlt diese
dieser kick diese etwa magische energie
eben die uns hilft zusammen das ganze
zusammen zu packen
und dann machen sich die musiker feiern
für den großen auftritt denn auch wenn
sie hier in basel heute ohne publikum
spielen im konzert wollen sie alles
geben
ab märz hofft concerto scirocco wieder
vor publikum spielen zu dürfen
wir drücken die daumen dass es klappt
[Musik]
das war unser ausflug zu den sternen
tja und nächste woche da schauen wir
nach ägypten vor zehn jahren startete
dort der arabische frühling und weckte
viele hoffnungen die danach brutal
zerstört wurden wir schauen wie es den
aktivisten von damals heute geht nun
gleich jetzt folgt auf sf1 die serie
meine geniale freundin bis bald wieder
[Musik]
da
[Applaus]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos